bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france les faits se sont se sont donc
déroulées ce matin que s'est il passé
précisément
bonjour à vous alors autour de six
heures et demie de 6h35 exactement
mes collègues de la police secours de
cannes au nombre de quatre sont montés
dans un véhicule pour partir en
patrouille et sécuriser la ville quand
ils ont vu un individu s'approcher du
véhicule prétextant une demande de
renseignements ce dernier a soudainement
ouvert la portière conducteur et a tenté
de poignarder
le chauffeur du véhicule au niveau du
thorax puis a fait le tour du véhicule
donc dans ce temps là les policiers
présents dans le véhicule donc sont
descendus le la fonctionnaire de police
qui se trouvait en tant que chef de bord
c'est à dire au niveau du siège passager
côté droit et sorti du véhicule et
l'individu est arrivé sur elle et a
tenté de la poignarder et les deux
collègues à l'arrière du véhicule sont
sortis et se sont bien en protection et
ont fait usage de leurs armes à feu à
trois reprises sur sur l'assaillant et
comment se porte au moment où on se
parle
la personne qui a été blessée
au couteau
alors je viens de les voir je suis
actuellement au commissariat de cannes
donc je viens de les voir je viens de
discuter avec eux
le policier qui a été touchée en premier
au niveau du gilet pare-balles donc il
n'a pas de blessures physiques
c'est plus un choc psychologique et
traumatique
mais il n'est pas blessé physiquement
ils sont ils sont très très choquée
ainsi que les trois autres policiers le
premier a été été poignardé au niveau du
thorax la deuxième chef de bord était à
ce point guard et enfin tout du moins
une tentative de deux coups de couteau
au niveau des bras et du visage et les
deux autres collègues qui ont fait usage
de leurs armes tous sont choqués
psychologiquement et se demande encore
comment ça a pu arriver au pied du
commissariat de cannes alors le suspect
aurait tenu des propos au nom du
prophète c'est ce qui est évoqué pour
l'instant le parquet antiterroriste n'a
pas été saisie ce que cela signifie que
la piste terroriste n'ait pas retenu
pour l'heure
alors écoutez moi je laisse faire mes
collègues de la police judiciaire qui
sont arrivés sur place assez rapidement
et pour faire les constatations et pour
procéder aux diverses diligence de de
l'anc est
effectivement il a été il a été évoqué
que l'individu avait agi au nom du
prophète dans quels termes on ignore
encore comment ça se manifeste en
vigueur encore l'enquêté en cours mes
collègues de la pj vont faire la lumière
sur cette affaire et si effectivement il
ya eu il ya il ya le prophète qui a été
évoqué ils tenteront de déterminer
quelles étaient les motivations de
l'assaillant l'intérieur gérald darmanin
c'est donc
rendue ce matin au commissariat central
doc n qu'est-ce qui vous a dit
alors effectivement on l'a vu ce matin
tout d'abord qu'il était qu'il était
tout coeur avec avec les policiers et
les cannois et à ceux à qui cette
affaire a touché de près
nous on lui a réitéré donc nos désirs à
savoir que effectivement on demande à ce
que les policiers soient reconnus et
sécurisé ça passe par une sécurisation
ça passe par des effectifs des annonces
présidentielles ont eu lieu en 2021 et
elle nous avait promis des renforts
policiers on n'a pas encore le compte
que ça soit calme que ça soit à nice ou
sur toutes les alpes maritimes on n'est
pas encore au nombre espéré et attendu
ensuite on demande à ce que les
policiers soient reconnus dans leur
métier parce qu'on se rend compte encore
une nouvelle fois aujourd'hui que le
métier de policier devenu très très
dangereux c'est le quatrième attentat
convoquons qu'on connaît sur sur la côte
d'azur 3 à nice et à cannes
aujourd'hui donc effectivement on
demande à ce que les policiers soient
reconnus on demande à ce que la justice
soit rendue
quand il ya une attaque de policiers que
ça soit du refus d'obtempérer à
l'agression physique ou verbale on
demande tout ça au ministre de
l'intérieur et en particulier
une reconnaissance aussi concernant les
alpes-maritimes savoir une
reconnaissance financière où on demande
à l'instar de nice qui l'a qu'il obtenu
l'année dernière une prime de
fidélisation pour fidéliser justement
les fonctionnaires police et des
collègues qui travaillent sur le
département parce que ça devient
difficile de travailler sur le
département quant au niveau sécuritaire
qu'au niveau qu'au niveau
comment
de la vie de tous les jours merci
beaucoup d'avoir pris le temps de
répondre sur rt france nicolas van sant
je rappelle que vous êtes secrétaire
départemental adjoint du syndicat
alliance police and haas dans les alpes
maritimes à merci